Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to ARK.
I...just lost a Tintoberry (like a doof)
but that doesn't matter because I've
got ENGRAM points to apply.
So, what I wanna do is I wanna
finish off the rest of the things that I have
unlearned like the...the-the
things there. (Poetic Mark '17)
But I also wanna learn
the slingshot, because if I can get a ranged
weapon- and I just discovered that the spear can also
be thrown and I haven't done that and that's why it broke so easily I
need to get more rocks and flint, but that's besides the point! (speaking hurriedly)
But... I know... for a fact, that I will be able to do what I need to do.
And that's good. (in low, sexiest voice)
So I'm gonna get there very soon, I don't have enough points for a simple bed,
but hopefully, I'll be able to make a Hide Sleeping Bag, ONCE I'M ABLE TO KILL ME SOME MONSTERS!
And that's what I'm going to be doing today- whoa.
That was weird...
What was with the glowy bits?
I don't know what that was all about, but hopefully it wasn't announcing my presence to anybody here.
Alright, whatever you say! I'm gonna bang up this rock!
Gimme some goodies, I love to get goodies, and goodies that goodies, goodies, goodies, goodies, goodies...(singing upbeat tune)
Just gonna keep swinging my thing... (gibberish) nom nom nom nom nom
I need water.  Holy shit I need water. Where am I gonna get water?
That's probably not drinkable, is it. It's probably the osh. Oh it's a whole lot of osh isn't it.
Nope, apparently it's not! Apparently its fresh water. Don't ask me why that is.
Okay more rock.  Heh. Heh. Heh. I- Ahhh I broke it! Ahhh! I broke everything! I'M SORRY!
Ahhh and it sank into the abyss... (like Mark's inhibitions)
Okay, well, alright then. I don't know why that happened. That was really weird.
But uh, I need to not gather so much stone this time. That's my problem there.
So I need... Ah,  godammit
Okay, so what I'm going to have to do is I have to go into the actual forest here. Because I don't have nearly enough shit to get what I need.
I need to make a crafting, uh ah an AXE
I need to get, I can make a HAT
And then I'm gonna put that on my HeAAd, cause that's where that goes. And then I'll be okay.
So, put that on my head. Yes, please. I look so much more like a pirate
Okay, so all I gotta do. I gotta get in there, I gotta get me some wOOd.
And then I'm gonna kill me some sons of bitches to be able to get things that I need to get.
Which is... I don't really know.
Where are the pipes? Is that just a pipe of water, that's cool.
Wood, wood, wood, wood.
Okay, not a lot of wood there.
Okay, crumbled to pieces, alright
Wood, wood, wood, wood. Oh fuck
Okay, I need to drop some rocks I guess.
I can get stones anywhere I don't really need them
Alright, so I'm gonna drop these. That was heavy.
Alright, I'm gonna DROOOoooopppp. These are fricking heavy as shit.
Oh, that's like total weight. Because I got so many of those. Okay, that's fine, so I should be good for now.
Then I, YES I can make the spears.
Craft five of those bad boys.
So I'm gonna be making those as I walk and whistle as I work.
And then suddenly...
My situation ain't lookin'  so dire. And that thing over there is gonna be pretty dead real soon.
Ooo, I got your number boy.
Oh I can throw it oh hell- Oops sorry didn't mean to do that, I didn't know how that worked.
Ah I'm just uncontrollable sometimes.
Can I get that back, good, you're on my target list
(Incomprehensible sounds) I'm a stupid dinosaur.
BErg, Blerg, Blerf, blerf, blerf, BLERF
Come on, come on get blurfed
Stop moving and get blurfed.
Dammit, godammit
BLERF
Oh hell yeah, oh hell yeah. Gimme your..
HIDE
Okay, I guess I got it already then
ga- YAY! VICTORY IS MINE!
I have been assured of it.
So now,
Anything that previously killed me is now an asshole,
and I am the winner!
That's how this goes, right?
That's how this goes
Oh yeah, I see how it is now
Y'all wish that you could apologize to me now
*whispers* unfortunately...
IT'S TOO LATE!
OH NO IT'S TOO LATE!
Oh ya gonna fly away, ya-
Hey gimme my spears back!
You asshole...
God, I need- I am carrying way too much shit...
Alright
K, how many more spears?
Four?!
Love it
Give 'em to me
I'ma craft this 'cause I think I got- Do I have meat?
I DO have meat but not enough.
I need more meat (͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Ooh...
Ooh- That's- That's scary...
I'ma GET YOUuu! Hahahahaha
What're gonna do? Whoa!
Ahaha-ha... AhaHA! Somehow I got meat out'a ya and CHITIN.
I dunno chi- OW SHIT!
Hey, what're ya doin- WHOA!
Got a swarm on me.
Ah- sha- sha- auhhhhh! (mating call)
HiYAAAaah!
Hiya- HiYAAAAAH!
HIYAAAAH!
Hiy- HIYAAAAH!
I killed somethin'...
Oooh, I did! Okay.
♪LLLLa Bu Ba Bu Ba Booooh~♪
Ahhhh' right! Got that...
I think the axe is marginally bet- Ooh, got this one too!
♪AHHH-Du Da Du Da Duuuuu~♪ I love whistling while I work.
OKAY, got those assholes! And this forest looks PRETTY... PROVIDING...
Nice, NICE... I devicated in excitement. Hell yeah!
Ah, fuck yeah.. I'm doing SO much better this time, aren't I guys? AREN'T I?
I'm gonna be a surVIVER.
I can't- I'm too heavy- I can't- I can't even... move. Alright that's cool too, I guess...
Shit.. alright. I don't need this. Drop all these...
Ooh, that's not right... Drop item... Pffthe! I was about to drop ABSOLUTELY EVERYthing I had. That would have been... STUPID.
Whoa! Who's doing that? Who's there?
Oh, hey!
Hey, yeah...
I KNOW...
You really shouldn't mess with me. Alright, I got to get rid of something here. (gets attacked)
Whoa! Hey, hey! Whoa, I can't see! Where are ya at?
Where're ya at? HUH?
Oh, there you are!
Think you want to mess with ME?! HUH?
Want to mess with meh? OHHH, I see you!
You think you can't be seen? HAH, you look pretty stupid with a spear sticking outa- Goddammit...
Alright, you're dead! OH, you're DEAD!
Yea- Yeah, you're dead. Yeah, you're dead. Yeah, you're dead. YEAH, you're dead.
Ohh, FUCK you're DEAD.
Ahh, Gimme some FOOOOD...
Oh, you want to be dead as WELL? Aww, missed ya... Ohh, just by that much. Oh, you're a dodgy one...
Oh, what's THAT? OH, SHIT! I'm out of- Oh, GOD! I'm out of-
OHHH, FFFFUUCKING NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
WHAT'S A TRUE DAWN?!
FUCK!
Alright, so I'ma do what I haven't done, and I'ma try and go to my body.
Okay, so it's to the South... Wherever the hell THAT is..
Do I have a map? I DOOoo. I DO have a map...
So I just got to go... find the ocean front and then-  fwrohhh, that's a snake.
Ohh, that's a death... Ohh that's also a death...
AHAH! I think I know where I am.
Maybe I don't... Maybe that's all a lie... Maybe I have no idea where I am...
I should've been looking at the tower... Goddammit, why'd I have to die? That's a big thing...
I got large animal feces... PERFECT!
I think...?
Oh, boy... Alright... Okay, well this ain't good. I'ma- snake again...
Fucking snakes... Assholes...
Titanboa, haha... That's good... That's good to know... *mumbles*
OH, What the fffucking... Are you KIDDING me?!
Again! With the fuckin' SNAAKE?!
GODDAMMIT, that snake is out to GET me!
OKAY, like I said, I'M king of this jungle, and I will be respected. Ignore the fact that I died like ten thousand times...
It's time to get down to business.
I need HIDE... 'cause I need to make a BED.
If I'm gonna make a bed, I'ma gonna get- *mumbles* That guy is FAAST.
Oh, he KNOWS... *fart noise*
Well, I know apparently 'cause I just shit my pants but...
Oh, he knows. NNNOO you don't! DON'T SPIT AT ME! DON'T SPIT ON ME! OOOhhh...
Not gonna get- Not gonna get me!
NNNot gonna get me!... WHOA, what the FUUCK?!
You wanna fffuck with ME? Bro- woah, I got you.
Got your number! Oh fuck. Good thing I got backups!
Ahh shit. Ahhhh come on.
No-no-no-no. Not today please, I... just GOT BACK!
NOOO!
Where is he- Wha- I can't sw-ahhh FUCK!
I'm just swinging wildly and backing up.
Wait AM I UNCONCIOUS?! Really?!
Well GET UP!! (high pitch)
Oh you gotta be kidding me..
You've got to be kidding me...
OH Come on... (decreased pitch)
Uh... don't kill me I ju- I litera-ahhhh! I literally JUST GOT BACK!!
I did everything!
If you kill me I swear (very soft voice)...
You gotta be joking me... I'm cursed. I'm stuck in a perpetual loop. If he keeps BITING me, I'm gonna keep loosing consciousness..
I don't know how to get back up.
The fuck is happening (quietly)
(quiet pitter-patter)
THE fuck is happening. Please... just let me wake up.
And I'm gonna run.
I'm gonna run, I'm gonna run, I'm running! NOO COME ON NOO! God Dammit. Just FUCKING DIE!
Oh no..
Let me get in my safe house...
If I fall over I'll fall over in here!
JESUS!
This guy is out of fucking control!
(munching noise)
That guy is out of his goddamned mind! Fucking TROODON!
JESUS. Ok, what did I get out of that. Did I even get a HIDE?
I got three (3). I need many more.. (spoken quietly)
Oh my God...
You've gotta be kidding, he is, he is fucking relentless.
Why? Why is this one dude so fucking- no God dammit NO God DAMMIT God Dammit just DIE!
You FUCKING ASSHOLE! Just DIE! (higher pitch towards end)
HOW?! Oh my God are you kidding me.
You fffucking..
OHHHH!! Of course! I PASS OUT on your CORPSE!
Ohhh boy (spoken quietly and softly)
But I killed it.
And that's what matters. I killed it, IT'S DEAD! I'M NOT! I'M GONNA WAKE UP, he's not gonna wake up.
Holy shit. That was- (mumbling). WHY IS A- SMALL LITTLE LEVEL TEN (10) DINOSAUR that fucking difficult?
I don't know...no idea. (quietly)
Get up. Come on, up, up, up, up, up, up, Up, UP! UP! There we go.
Why am I- WHAT!?!
ARE YOU FUCKING KIDDING ME?! ARE YOU. FUCKING. KIDDING. ME?!
You- Oh, Where am I?
Are you fucking kidding me.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
(door opening) Oh my God. Where am I?
Holy, SHIT...
(water nioses) Oh, man...
Don't... (spoken tiredly) WHHY!?
WHHY?!
Fuck OFF!
Fuck OFF! OH, JEZUS...
OH, GODDAMMIT! OH, WHAT THE FUCK?! Goddammit...
OH, man...
This happens every time I play a survival game. EVERY. SINGLE. TIME. Every single time.
I get to a point where I'm actually doing- I start out fine- nothing's killing me. NOTHING AT ALL is killing me.
And I start out JUST fine.
And THEN, it gets to a POINT...
...Where everything wants to FUCKING KILL ME.
(reading the sign) "This site was the first base of the hero tribe, the Avengers. Unfortunately, the original building was lost in the infamous wrecking ball event.
They then headed West to Red Obelisk."
I don't know what ANY of that is. I know none of that.
I'm a newcomer here and this land HATES me.
And I'm not going to leave 'till I get REVENGE.
This episode is NOT over.
It's not OVER! I'm not done...
(whispered) I've got unfinished business...
(defecated)
I shitted all over the place. My BUSINESS, apparently, is done now.
Alllright, this TIME I'm not messing around. I'm not gonna build a house until I've got enough hide to make a bed.
That's what I'm gonna do... That's what I gotta do... and I'm not gonna play two games about this. I'm gonna FUCKing kill that Dodo...
(dinosaur growls) Ignore that guy...
Kill... (high soft pitch) kill, kill, (quieter then others) kill, kill, kill
I'm (pitch escalates) GONNA KILL this goddamned Dodo.
Ahh yeah, you're dead now. Sorry...
Get hide AND meat. (loudness increases)THAT'S HOW you do it.
JEZUS, I got more hide from that guy than any of the other ones that I've found
(funny voice) Oh, nooo, right in your butt. Ooh, that's gotta suuck.
Succs to (loudness increases) SUUUUCC. (͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Dodos make for easier PREY.
(mumbled) Ahhhhh...
Easy. Okay, this is MUCH better.
(funny voice) OH, NOO! NOOOO!
DODO! That's- yeah- That's why they're called Dodos 'cause that's what they shout when you're trying to kill 'em.
(funny voice) OHH, NOO!
Arrughright, I've got THE HIDE. I can't believe it was that easy just to get HIDE.
I can't believe those gates over there are purple, but that's another story. Fashion travesty aside, I've got more important things to DO.
(spoken quietly) So what I'm gonna do... nestled in the hills... is going to be my home...
This is my land... NOW...
(loudness increases) YOU ALL (spoken lower) are going to be witness... to MY... WORLD.
Can't believe how many times I've had to do THIS...
Okay, I'm not gonna waste that. I'm gonna biuld the hide sleeping bag.
I'm gonna get a water skin 'cause that's a good idea.
Make gloves, make the boots. I've got ALL the shit unlocked.
Okay, put on cloth gloves and... where's my boots? Auuuuh, I don't see my boots here. Where's my boots?
I know I ha- I know I crafted boots. I know I did.
Apparently, I DID NOOOOT, but I WANT 'EM
Hmm, alright, I not gonna do with out 'em because I want armor.
When I'm going into this (stressed) WORLD,- This world SUCCS ASS- I want armor.
Okay, I can DO that.
I wouldn't mind a slingshot. I've got a lot of, like, spears, and I don't want to have to CONSTANTLY rely on making spears 'cause they're heavy anyway.
I need to hunt more Do-dos.
Oh, my booties! I gotta put 'em on. *whispers* Puttin on the boots. THERE we go! I got it good- alright.
(quiet pitter-patter)
(munching noise)
okay
Finally..
*whispers*  riight hidden away in this little nook- that's a nice nook
*very quietly* that's a nice nook.
Right there, right there. No one's gonna know about it, no one's gonna care about it, no one's gonna bOther me
No one's gonna bother me when I'm nuzzled up here- thiz is- how many times have I made this goddamn base?
Over an over an over again.
But this time, no one's gonna bother me
Not this time, not eVER again- Understood?
Not gonna kill that tree 'cause it's my cover
*game grunts*
Make a bOx-
So I can put shit in it!
Then I'm gonna put my slEEPING BAG DOWn
And I know it's not permanent, it's single use but, at least I'll- I'ma gonna try and go out and get more shit for the rest of what I need
But, I'm gonna put my sleeping bag down, I'm gonna put my storage box down!
*upset* ooohhhhh really? It's too small in here, uh?
Oooohh good for youuu!
Ohh good for you- oh o o o o- aaand... BOOP
Ahaha! HA Haha!
Hahaha ha, Alright!
But I can put that, there! Apparently that doesn't bug anybody
Heeerrbadurba! Okay, got it!
*sighs* Okay
So then, I have this shit here, I can put my thatch away- I'll keep a little bit of it. I can put-
I can put half of all my shit away, anyway
I need to put my water skin down here
Okay!
I- I'm hesitant to say this, but we're doing pretty good.
Doing better than we were. So I'm gonna go get some more goddamn kills.
*quietly* oh, of course it's foggy
Just to make the fog a war a bit more interesting, uh?
*very quietly* We don't need that-
No one needs that.!
*clanking* EHH!- *hits dodo* OW!
Ehw! Okay
Hip! Hup! Hey! Huppo! Okay
The thing is, I have no relitive scale with which I need to kill by..
Like dodos are obvious, they don't fight back, they're pretty easy- and it just shit its pants at the sight of me!
Oh, and it's dead. Easy as that.
*sing-ish* Boop ba doopa doop
Okay, is that enough to make a bed? I do not know.
Nah, I need.. uhhh? More- more hide
Alright, so what I'm gonna do, I need to test out how this, um,
How this ssslingshot works.
*pickax breaks* Okay then!
Okay, so I'm gonna test out how the slingshot works by hitting and running,
That big boy.
Where ya goin' there?
*quietly* shabooskee
Oh, well that-that doesn't seem very powerful...
Oh! Well you never know! We'll see what it does. Shoosh!
Nope.
Shibey!
Hehehe
*in funny voice* What was that?? Wahhh I gotta get outta here!
Ah, ya coward. Ya coward!
Did you shit your pants on the way outta here?
You coward..
Glug. Okay! So we're doing better, but nO, I'M NOT DONE YET!
I wanna take out something big. I got the backup pl- well I mean,
This- this- this'll do, I guess
Here, let me see how much damage this does to this bad boy
oooOOHHH SIDe winder!
How many shots does it take to get to the center of this dodo pop?
Uhhh is it out?
Boink! Oh, it's unconscience!
Well, better.. kill it  *dodo honk*
*singing- ish* I need some mooOOre, I need some mOore
Alright, got that one! Alright, is that enough hide? I believe it might be.
So if I go back now, I should be able to make a PERmanent bed,
Which is good because that way, things go a little bit better for me, sorry, and I won't die and then loose all of my pre-gress.
Alright, so I need to have, to make a regular bed, which is reusable,
I need wood, I need fiber, I believe I have... wood in there, so I just need to get more fiber
Let's just gather- oop I think that was enough
And then in, oo *game grunts*
*quietly* Uh, no, oh no, no. No, no, no.
I can't, I can't enter my abode!
Oh no!
Oh no! NOoo!
Well shit. Alright then.
I'll just have to make a bigger abode then, in time I guess.
But the answer is I don't have the wood in there anyways, soo, fuck it
I'm just gonna go ahead and make another
Yay! I leveled! Okay, I'm gonna make it double wide, I'm gonna make a good ol' double wide.
Oh no, you're dead, oh so sad, where'd you body go?
Get your body back here, I need you! Eh, screw you then.
*quietly* that's how you're gonna be, bitch.
Okay, here we go, for realzes this time.
Main entrance, nuzzled in that tree- I am slooow but I'm moving
We're moving, we're moving
Okay and, there, okay
And then another one right there, alright. And then the side walls there,
A side wall there,
Side wall there, side wall there, side wall there
Why'd I make two doors? Goddamn it, I'm an idiot (no you're not)
*in funny voice* Just in case I need an escape route
And the roofs, nice, riight there aand riiight there
Okay! Alright! :-)
That should be everything I need and then once I'm in here- I probably just lost all the materials I need to be able to make the goddamn bed
Which was the whole point of this- yup, wood and fiber, okay, got it..
Okay! So I should have the materials, and I got my house, and we're all good here and I'm very happy
I got my bed, put it down, make it, it's great, got it; once it's down, I'm good.
Put it in my goddamn thing
Where'd ya go? There you are, I'm gonna put you in here, we're all good, get these outta here, I don't need these anymore
Ah, for some reason I have them still.
Open this up, mY DOUBLE WIDE, IT'S Real nice in here and
what do ya know?
Shabooskee
Uhh.. I said, shabooskee
OOHHA!
It's mah bed! It's meh bed
I'm gonna call it 'MUHBED' and it's gonna be my bed forever-
So with that, this nightmare is oveerrr!
And that is the end of this episode.
So thank you everybody so much for watching, I hope you cheered me on and in the next episode I'm gonna go hunt for bigger prey
And have a permanent base in which to do this
And NO, I'm not gonna look up any guides because that would be cheating
WAh?
NO! It'd be- alright, okay, it wouldn't be cheating, but it wouldn't be the Markiplier way, and that's the only way I know how to do things. So,
*outro starts playing* Thank you everybody so much for watching, I hope you all are enjoying this, I actually am, very much. I gotta level up a bit though..
Ah jee, I'm gonna get my fortitude up, hell yeah
And then I'll see more in the next episode.
So thank you everybody so much for watching,
And as always, I will see you, in the next video, Bue Bye!
(Mark said 'Thank you everybody so much for watching' three times... noice)
(I hope you, as the viewer, are having a good day/night :-), bye)